Let me tell you about some aggressive
and some very safe by comparison
advertising scaling strategies when
you're on your path to million-dollar
months. One of the most important
variables is being able to punch up.
Being able to take something that's
working, scale the [__] out of it, milk
it for all it's worth, and make a ton
more money. It's one of the most
critical parts about scaling a million
dollar months. And in this specific
video, and I want to be very fair when I
say this, there's other videos on this
channel where I'll talk about some
additional scaling strategies, things
that relate to like back-end upsells,
taking somebody from low ticket to high
ticket and ascending them up, increasing
lifetime value, selling to rich people,
and being able to make more AOV per sale
on average, strategies that can get you
more pips. But in this specific video,
we're going to be talking about
advertising scaling strategies
specifically. meaning you have a
specific set of campaigns or a campaign
that you now want to scale the [__] out
of and be able to make a fuckload more
money with. So, if that's the case,
you're in that specific situation, pay
attention. This one's for you. If you're
a new person to the channel, you've
never been here before, welcome. We talk
about million-dollar months around here.
That's all we care about. That's all we
talk about. Whether you're trying to get
your first million a month or add that
next million a month to what you do,
you're in the right place. We don't make
any income claims, though. No, no,
there's no earning potential with any of
these videos. All I'm doing is handing
down the lessons of the people who have
been there, done that, passing them down
into these little bite-sized clips for
you on YouTube. So, welcome in if you're
new. It's a pleasure to have you with
us. And of course, if you're already a
subscriber, welcome back. Always a
pleasure to have you. Got another banger
for you here today. Let's get started.
So, in front of us, we have this
spectrum, right? And you'll notice on
the far left, we have the word safe and
then on the far right, we have the word
risky. That's because there's a
tremendous difference in the scaling
strategies that you can deploy that are
going to be wildly riskier or far a lot
safer. So, let's just get started with
some of the most aggressive ones. First,
I think that's very fun. At the specific
time I'm filming this video, there's a
holiday here in the United States, and I
have a handful of clients that are
running holiday themed sales. As a
result of that, I have a finite window
where I can scale the living [__] out of
a specific campaign in order to get the
most out of it. Now, as a result of
that, I don't have the opportunity to be
able to stay safe and cozy and, you
know, milk these campaigns slow and
steady. No, no. I have to do the far
riskier strategies when it comes to
scaling to be able to punch up and hope
fingers crossed that the market holds
that my cost per purchase or my cost per
lead holds and that my AOV holds as well
as I take some of these more aggressive
risks because some of these risks that
we'll talk about they can blow the
entire profitability of the campaign if
things go south. Thus why they're on the
far riskier end of the spectrum. So
let's get started with number one. So
this very first strategy we call it
surfing. I want to give a huge shout out
to one of my longtime buddies, a guy
named Tim Bird. Have you never heard of
Tim Bird? He's an advertising OG. I've
learned from Tim over the years. I've
had Tim speak at my internet earners
summit back in the day, which was an
event we did where we'd get a big house
in Beverly Hills, get about 150ish
people there, get a bunch of people who
make seven, eight, nine figures a year
from the internet with internet money on
stage speaking to folks. It's an
incredible event series. I think I did
about two or three of them if I remember
correctly. And uh anyway, Tim spoke at
one of those events on and off over the
years. Had a handful of conversations
and talk time with Tim, spoken at some
of his events and vice versa. So anyway,
this specific strategy with surfing
comes from Mr. Tim Burton. So quick
shout out and credit to Tim. All right,
let's use the example that you have a
campaign like I did literally earlier
this past day where it starts off at
$1,000 a day. With this strategy, I
can't stress this enough. I launched a
campaign. It was a holiday related sale.
It was for a ticket event for a few
months later, but it was like the
earliest bird pricing. And we themed
that earliest bird pricing around the
holiday that we were experiencing at the
time of promotion. So, I started it off
with a random budget of $1,000 a day. I
determined that would be a great place
to start because I knew I was going to
bias towards this extremely aggressive
surfing strategy. So, as a result of
starting at the $1,000 a day, I let
about 8 hours pass. After that initial 8
hours passed, I launched this bad boy at
midnight Eastern Standard Time. I woke
up in the morning, took a peek at the
campaign, and it was in a good spot. I
had about a $57 cost per purchase. Cost
per purchase. We can also just call it
cost per result. And I had about a
$90ish AOV, so I was profitable just shy
of a 2:1. Now, at that point, I was
like, time to punch up. What do I want
to punch it up to? the concept of
surfing is, and there's many different
ways to surf. Um, I've learned it from
Tim a little differently than how I'm
going to articulate it to you, but
nonetheless, I still like uh this
specific like high-risk version that
I've done. I kicked it up at that point
from a,000 a day to 3,000 a day. Now, at
this point, I want to remind you it's 8
in the morning, okay? I only have a
couple more hours until midnight. So, I
kick it up. I want to at that point wait
about three hours and I want to see
where my cost per result is and I also
want to see where my AOV is. What ended
up happening in this case was really
good. So when I go check the campaign 3
hours later, it's now 11:00 a.m. Eastern
Standard Time. At this point, my CPR, my
cost per result, actually dropped down a
little bit. It was now $51. Phenomenal.
In addition to that, my AOV dropped just
a little bit. It was at 87 bucks at this
point in the day. So, unfortunately for
me, my OV started to slip a little bit,
but it was questionable as to why. I
wasn't going to make any conclusions
yet. I wanted to continue riding the
wave. So, at that point, again, we're at
11:00 a.m. I doubled it. I went from
3,000 a day to 6,000 a day within the
same campaign. I didn't relaunch the
campaign. I didn't do anything else. And
this is a very simple campaign, by the
way, in terms of the structure. I had
the campaign. The campaign was set for
CBO in this case. I could have done CBO
or [__] It really didn't matter cuz I
had one ad set. Inside of that one ad
set, I had a warm audience stack and
that was it. That warm audience stack
consisted of a few different things. Web
audiences, email list, all social
interaction, video viewers, I think lead
form interaction I peppered in there as
well for the handful of times that we've
done that. From there, I had a set of
dynamic ads. And my dynamic ads in this
case, the client didn't shoot any
videos. We didn't want to whip up
anything. They gave it to me at like,
dude, this is actually kind of crazy.
So, I launched at midnight like I was
saying. Um, I got the ads like 11
something that night. So, I didn't have
that much time to do anything else. I
threw five body copy variations. And in
this case, I do want to point out we've
run a similar funnel to this in the
past. So, I already had some good proven
copy from that past campaign. And after
reading it, I realized like it was still
technically applicable to this. I just
had to update it a little bit around the
theme sale. So, that was the structure.
Okay. So, anyway, at this point, another
3 hours passed. I'm sitting now at about
two in the afternoon, Eastern Standard
Time, and I was at 6K a day. Now, here's
what was cool. It's actually really good
news. I had a $54 cost per result when I
checked it at this point. I'd gotten off
a pretty good chunk of spend. Nothing
too crazy, but still it was pretty good.
I don't remember the exact AOV at this
point, but I was in the 90s for my AOV.
Went back up a little bit. So, I was
feeling good. Now, here is where things
can get a little crazy, depending on how
you choose to surf from this point
forward. going from $1,000 a day to
$6,000 a day within about what is that a
14-hour window. That's not that bad.
Believe it or not, when you have the
audience size, which this specific
client's a relatively well-known
personal brand, their warm audience is
tremendously large. I got a lot of scale
potential. And very important to note,
I've already had ceilings that I've
tapped that were far above $6,000 a day
on this specific warm audience. In the
past on campaigns that I've scaled
differently, I've been able to get up to
about $55,000 a day inside of a warm
audience for, believe it or not, a cost
per purchase campaign. So, I felt pretty
good about the amount of potential that
I had left here. So, to be clear, at
this point, it's very important to
understand what I peppered in at the
beginning of this in terms of this whole
like risk spectrum. This is where
surfing can to a degree really [__] you.
Remember, as the wave gets bigger and
you're surfing that wave, god forbid you
fall, those waves can sometimes
literally kill you. You know, they can
drown you or the level of impact that
the wave has when it crashes down on you
can crush your bones. There's a lot of
bad things that can happen as the wave
gets bigger. But at 6K a day, like I
said, relative to the fact that we've
scaled campaigns in this specific
account to 55k a day on that specific
audience type, there was still a lot of
potential to go. And so, at this point,
I was like, "All right, let's get a
little more aggressive." So, that's
exactly what we did. I'm just playing
the doubles game if you can't tell yet.
going from a th000 a day to 3,000 a day.
That was just a random choice of
choosing to triple it so I can get the
number bigger faster. Um, at this point,
we then doubled it to 6K a day. I then
doubled it again. You'll notice in the
next series of what I do, I actually get
a little more aggressive than that. So,
again, I let another 3 hours go by. That
next 3 hours turns into 5:00 p.m. EST.
We're towards the tail end of the day
now. Again, I don't actually remember
the exact CPA at this point in the day
for my uh for my cost per result. And I
also don't remember the exact AOV, and I
won't make it up for you guys. I only
tell you the things I actually remember
and know. So again, I was still in the
50s and I was still in the 90s for my
cost per result, my my my overall AOV.
And that's what mattered. That's that's
what truly meant the entire world to us
on this account was staying in that
range because as long as we were in that
range, we can continue to double up.
Okay. Now, there's a few things to
consider from this point. I'm later in
the day. I'm at about 5:00 p.m. on the
East Coast. I'm at about 2 p.m. on the
West Coast inside of the United States.
That was the geographic area that I was
choosing to target for this campaign.
The time of day will dictate wildly what
I'm going to choose to do and what I'm
not going to choose to do. At this
point, you have to rely on historical
patterns and trends within the account
for determining the level of risk that
you want to take next, especially as you
get to these higher levels of spend. I
determined based on the fact that I
launched a campaign at midnight prior on
a weekend and saw great results from
essentially midnight through 8:00 a.m.
the following morning that everything
would be fine if I just rammed a
fuckload of spend. The only downside is
is that I'm going to be asleep. So, I
could rely on automated rules to
obviously determine if my cost per
result goes too high. It just shuts off
the campaign, which is what you want to
choose to do if obviously you're going
to be asleep. However, in this case, I
generally was going to stay up until
about midnight, maybe 1:00 a.m. And I
was going to ride this out until about
that time frame. And at that point, I
would choose to set up my automated
rules. I wasn't doing anything. Wasn't
going to leave the house. I was in the
house and I was checking the account
every like every other hour or so. So, I
was like, let's get aggressive. At this
point, I went big
and I did a little triple. So, I went up
36k a day. Now, going from $1,000 a day
to $36,000 a day within the same day
with several increments in between. I
just want to point out a few critical
things before I continue to talk. Number
one, the reason that this is at the
level of risk that it is is because this
can wildly [__] up the performance of an
account and a campaign. Okay, this in
itself can cause for a tremendous lift
in cost per result. If you hit a
hypothetical ceiling somewhere in
between the jumps in ad spend, so let's
use the example that I was not aware
that I've already taken this specific
audience in the past with this specific
standard event to $55,000 a day. I would
be a little more cautious. I'd tell you
that right now just to be extremely
direct with you and pepper that in as
kind of like a risk disclaimer to a
high-risisk strategy. If I did not know
the ceiling of a specific standard event
correlated to a specific audience and
correlated to a specific offer, I
wouldn't necessarily feel as comfortable
or as confident as I did in this
specific scenario to take it up even as
high as I did at $12,000 a day, let
alone to then triple it and go to 36k a
day. The reason that I felt very
confident and competent to be able to do
that was because of the patterns and
historical data that I had to lean into.
I've already taken that warm audience to
55k a day literally for the same offer
just with several months in between that
last time I promoted it and this time of
promoting it. I did not. The only real
variable here was I did not promote it
with a holiday sale last time. I had
only had the opportunity to promote it
as an early bird sale and we had some
inflationary holidays that we didn't
theme it around. So that was one mistake
that we wanted to overcome this specific
goaround of promoting this. And outside
of all of that, the 55K a day, the same
exact audience, it was also the same
exact standard event and the same funnel
type. You understand? So, it's like the
confidence was there. That's a time
where you can lean into something that's
a little more risky. It's like when I go
drive one of my supercars and
hypothetically, let's use the example,
I'm driving it relatively fast and
there's a little bit of water on the
road. It's like naturally I can't be as
aggressive as I would be if it was a
great day. I'm in warm weather. I've
already driven the car and warmed it up.
The tires are warmed up. I've already
driven that exact route before. I know
how the car handles. I've just recently
serviced the car. I know to the degree
the tires are currently in in terms of
their conditions. It's like that enables
you to be a little more confident behind
the vehicle the wheel and take more
risks. You understand? It's like you
don't do this kind of [__] on something
that you have no historical bias to to
have confidence in. I want to be fair
for the few of you that watch this video
cuz at the end of the day, let's be
honest, right? When you're trying to
scale to a million a month or you're
trying to tack on the next million a
month, you likely have a high risk
profile. like you're likely willing to
put your balls on the table and keep
them on the table. And I just want to
make sure I I pepper in a little
disclaimer, which is don't overlever
yourself because at the end of the day,
this specific client makes a few million
dollars a month. Them essentially having
an unfortunate return, let's use the
example that this return went negative.
It's like, well, in reality, the event
that we're promoting in this case is a
challenge funnel. It's a virtual event.
So, if something does go wrong and I
actually quote unquote like lose money
on the front-end rorowaz here with the
ticket sale, really doesn't mean [__]
because at the end of the day, I have a
really high probability to be able to
get a return because I'm selling
something super high ticket at the thing
that I'm selling here. You understand?
So, it's like that also helps reduce the
risk, right? If I was just selling
something directly that's low ticket,
and I highly doubt that any of you would
do that, but regardless, if you're
watching this and for some reason you
are, you should probably reconsider. But
regardless, you have a fail safe. you
know, with the amount of money that you
make, the level of risk that you can
take, factoring in that it's not going
to financially ruin you if things go
wrong. And in this case, we have the
fail safe of look, we're not even really
trying to make money on this. Like, it's
just cool to make money on this and be
ROI positive. The real thing we're
trying to make money on is the backend
thing, which in this case is about two
months away from the time I'm promoting
it right now. So, can't stress that
enough. Okay? So, anyway, I then kick it
up. Okay? And we get pretty aggressive.
Now, at this point, I run this with no
other changes through midnight. Okay?
Because at midnight on this specific
night, that's when I was going to go to
bed. That's when I wanted to set up my
automated rules. Now, this actually got
pretty [__] crazy. Give or take the
time of day, I was in the 60s for my
cost per result throughout the rest of
the evening, but I'd also seen it as low
as the 40s for my cost per result. By
the time that bedtime came around at
about midnight, I was in the low 60s.
Okay? So, I was a little bit inflated
comparatively to where I was at, but not
much. But it's important to note just
because it's only a couple dollar
difference or like a 10 10ish dollar
difference that doesn't necessarily
matter. What matters is the percentage
difference. The percentage difference is
something that you have to absolutely
factor in when you make these kinds of
decisions. Cuz if you don't, you could
see, as an example, if I was at $100 for
my cost per result and I inflated 30%,
it's 130 bucks. If I was at $1,000 for
my cost per result and I inflate 30%,
that's $1,300 now. So, it's like, you
know, the percentages, although again,
they're less meaningful when they're at
smaller levels of the number being
smaller, it doesn't have as much impact
to have a higher percentage change. But
still, it's like we're trying to be as
profitable as we can, and we we want to
keep that in mind. Um, also an
unfortunate thing that happened was I
was now in the 80s, specifically the
mid80s for my AOV. So, I had compressed
my rorowaz a little bit by tripling up
this budget. Now, I did not lose
confidence, though. I had determined
that like, okay, although this was good
at some points and kind of bad at others
and my AOV had dropped a little bit.
That's likely just because I tripled the
[__] budget from $12,000 to $36,000.
And I had only allowed, if you really
look at it, about 7 hours to pass, you
know, cuz I took it from 5:00 p.m. to
midnight on the Eastern time zone here.
So, at this point, I was going to let it
ride. But I was going to go to bed with
some automated rules in place. And those
automated rules were pretty simple. They
were, I am going to ensure that if my
cost per result goes above $70, it just
immediately cuts off. That was
essentially the rule. Okay. Moral of the
story, very important you understand
this next part because this next part's
very important. If I remember the
original way that Tim Bird taught the
surfing strategy to me, this was taught
to me as, okay, at midnight, you ideally
want to roll the budget back. Okay, so
what you originally started with in this
case is what you would actually want to
reset the campaign's budget to going
into the following day. I personally
don't like that approach. I want to let
it ride. I don't like to reset it all
the way down then and have to repeat
this process. It's a very hands-on
process to do this. When I reach a scale
and it's working, I'd rather maintain
that scale. So, at this point, we're
just going to bed with it at $36,000.
And we got some automated safety rules
in place. So, that's what we do. And
here's the cool thing. This is actually
really sick. So, over these next 48
hours, I don't touch it. I don't want to
increase it further. I actually, believe
it or not, and this is a little bit
irresponsible to a degree, but I like to
push my clients. They said, "You have a
$40,000 total budget for this, but if
we're profitable, you have an unlimited
budget." Now, generally, when a client
says that, they don't actually mean it.
But when I hear them say that, I take it
very literally. So, anyway, they give me
a $40,000 budget. I had already blown
through that $40,000 budget into the
early morning hours of the following
day. At $36,000 the previous day and at
$36,000 the current day. Oh, and by the
way, I want to point out in the first
day I didn't spend a full $36,000. I
think I spent into like the low 20s at
this pace, um I did not reach the full
$36,000, nor did I go above that. That's
kind of the disappointment of surfing is
um you don't actually reach what you set
as the daily budget the first day. You
absolutely can the second day, assuming
you don't lift it higher like I did. So
anyway, that following 48 hours, the
main reason I didn't want to scale
further is the budget. I needed to reach
out to the client, ensure that they like
understood the level of daily spend that
we were at, where the profitability was,
and get the official thumbs up that it
was okay. and it was midnight, so I
didn't have the opportunity to do that
at that time. I had to wait until the
following morning. Automated rules were
in place for safety. I figured knowing
this client had worked with them for a
long time, everything would be okay. So
anyway, I wake up the following morning.
I get the approval from the client.
They're super excited. Everybody's
happy. But on my end, as the advertiser
at this point, I don't necessarily want
to push it higher. My upper limit for
this campaign is going to be 55,000 a
day. I know that. I don't even have the
ability to double it at this point.
Realistically, all I have the
opportunity to do is get to about 50ish,
maybe 60K a day tops. But 55k being the
true upper limit realistically. I want
this to stabilize over that following 48
hours. I want to see my cost per result
and I want to see my total AOV. I want
to see these become stable. Okay,
ideally in the original range that I saw
them in when I was way down here at
$1,000 a day. Not every time is that
realistic, but because I saw my AOV and
my cost per result stay within a very
similar range every time that I punched
up all the way until I tripled the
budget, I figured that I could get back
within that range. I just needed time.
Generally, stability can come through
time. And in this case, it did. It took
until about the 36th hour, though. So,
that full next 24 hours, I was within
this same general AOV range of the 60s
for my cost per result and the 80s, low
80s at that for my AOV. It took until
about the next day, halfway through the
next day to be able to see it stabilize
again. My cost per result that climbed a
little tiny bit, but my AOV went up. We
made some backend changes specifically
to the upsell process, and that cut the
AOV at the high 90s again. So,
everything was AOK and we were spending
a lot more money. We got a lot more
buyers. This is one of the most
aggressive ways to scale. I want to
point out a very, very important caveat
to this whole initial scaling strategy.
This is not applicable for a lot of
people unless they are attempting to
scale a campaign hyperaggressively. The
best time frames to typically do this
are when you have something that you
have to milk in a rather short duration
of time or if you have a lot of [__]
money for a specific campaign and you
want to scale it fast, but start it with
a rather conservative test budget to a
degree. Once you see approved results,
you want to just punch up immediately.
Um, it is in terms of risk the highest
probability to have cost per result that
just wildly goes out of KPI really
quickly on you. And at that point, if
something does go wrong, you have to
reset the whole campaign. So, you would
relaunch the campaign. You'd likely pull
the budget all the way back down. And at
that point, you'd have some stability
again, and you'd have to go a little
slower. You wouldn't be able to punch up
as aggressively. And you also might have
to defer to some of the other scaling
strategies that are little less risky.
Um, one of the ones that's in the
middle, it is called the cost per result
or otherwise known as the cost per X
strategy. So, the cost per X strategy is
one of my favorites. It's pretty
simplistic. It follows some of the logic
of surfing. It just defines what you're
going to do to scale with a little bit
cleaner math. So, let's use the example
that I'm currently getting a $100 cost
per result. And let's use the example
that tomorrow I want to get an
additional 10 results. That would mean I
have to be able to spend an extra $1,000
a day on top of my existing daily budget
in order to have the potential to see
those extra 10 results. Make sense? That
would assume that my cost per result
stays the same. And that would also
assume that adding the additional budget
is obviously going to get me those
additional results. Now, a lot can go
wrong with the cost per X strategy, just
as with surfing. The cost per X strategy
specifically has the liability of a lot
of the same things as surfing does. It
can spin wildly out of control. It has a
high probability of failing to get you
the result that you want if your cost
per result inflates. Right? As an
example, I could add the additional
budget for 10 results. But in this case,
if my cost per result goes up 10 bucks,
I immediately remove the probability to
get that additional 10th result and I'm
going to have nine additional results.
And I'm also going to artificially
inflate my CPA. Both with surfing and
with the cost per X result. When they
hit, boy, do they [__] hit. You'll
know right away cuz your cost will stay
rather stable. Your AOV will stay rather
stable or your cost per result will stay
rather stable. And you're going to have
a great time because you're going to be
able to essentially scale more
aggressively and get the result that
you're after, assuming you don't run
square into the ceiling, which is what's
most probable to happen with both of
these specific aggressive scaling
strategies. You have in most instances
unknown ceilings to the audiences
correlated to the daily spend you're
going to be able to deploy into those
audiences with the specific standard
event and funnel that you're optimizing
with. and you're going to run square
into that [__] ceiling and it's going
to hurt and you're going to have to pull
back. The good news is you'll know the
ceiling a lot sooner. The bad news is
it's going to eat into that specific
day's profitability and it's going to
inflate your cost per results a little
bit. The cost per X strategy is
typically one of my go-tos. It is
aggressive, but it's in between because
it's not nearly as aggressive as what
surfing is comparatively. I don't like
to surf with the cost per X strategy.
What I generally do with the cost per X
strategy and what makes it a little
safer is I add time into the equation.
So, I'm typically going to do the cost
per X strategy today and then I'm going
to wait like two to three days. And then
after I see my cost per result has
stabilized and my AOV or the backend
statistics have stayed the same, I'm
going to do another cost per X strategy
adjustment and I'm going to scale up the
campaign. Again, this disrespects the
safest rule, which is generally to keep
everything within about a 10 to 30% per
day lift in budget. But when it works,
boy does it [__] work. It's just
riskier because it doesn't always work.
And as I mentioned, due to the fact that
you're inflating your cost dramatically,
that can erode your profitability just
like that. And if you're not attentive
to your account or you're too [__] and
you make the change too soon and you
shut it off, you're not giving it the
time that's necessary to have and
experience the potential. Something to
consider. Okay. One of the safest things
that you can do is the 10 to 30% per day
scaling strategy. Now, this is one of
those triedand-trude spreads around
amongst all advertisers type lessons.
It's arguably one of the safest. That's
why it's also one of the most known
amongst all advertisers. No specific
individual beyond the ad channels that
originated this one. It is again a
triedand- trueue strategy and it's on
the safer end of the spectrum. Thus why
the ad channels themselves recommend it.
You typically take whatever your current
budget is and you raise it by anywhere
from 10 to 30% per day. So generally
what it comes down to is you
incrementally scale from like 10% or 20%
or 30% on top of whatever your existing
budget is. So, if I start at $1,000 a
day budget, right, and I want to scale
today at 10%. That gives me additional
daily budget of hundred bucks. Now, my
new daily budget's $1,100. That's within
the same campaign. That's either added
to the [__] or the CBO part of the
campaign. Up to you, for however you
choose to do it. At that point, you're
typically going to be able to do that
over the following days. Sometimes you
have to add time into it as well and
wait like 24 to 48 hours, sometimes even
upwards of 72 hours before you can scale
it. Again, really depends on how much
budget you are starting off with. when
you start the scaling process. The cool
thing is if you do the math on the 10 to
30% a day scaling plan and you just
throw it into a Google sheet or an Excel
sheet, whatever you prefer, you'll
notice that 10 to 30% compounds really
quickly. Like you can go from like
couple hundred bucks a day to like tens
of thousands of dollars a day within a
30-day window depending on how often
you're able to scale 10 to 30%. The cool
part about 10 to 30% scaling windows is
generally you can do it every day.
Sometimes, as I mentioned, you have to
wait anywhere from like 2 to 3 days, 48
to 72 hours, and then you get the
opportunity to do it again. That'll
obviously slow your compounded effect to
get to bigger numbers faster. Sometimes
it's not appropriate to scale every day
relative to what type of funnel you're
running. So, let me also be clear. If
I'm doing a callunnel, as an example,
and I have a limitation on the quantity
of people that I can book calls into on
the closing team, I'm not going to be
able to bias towards the riskier end of
the spectrum. Like there's no way I'm
going to even be able to consider these
specific strategies due to the fact that
I have limitations of the quantity of
people I can book calls into. The only
time I can really take like the riskiest
strategies are when I have a cost per
purchase campaign. So it works really
well for low ticket to high ticket.
Works really well for like challenge
funnels like the specific example I gave
you with the AOV and and cost per result
examples for surfing. Um it arguably
simply put works really well when
there's just not sales people involved
on the back end. That's really important
to understand. It also works really well
for webinars. So, if you wanted to run a
webinar and the webinar is doing direct
to checkout, again, works really well to
be able to use a riskier strategy. Now,
it's important to note typically the
safer strategies doesn't necessarily
mean it's more of a [__] scaling
strategy because, as I said, if you do
the math, scaling 10 to 30% a day is a
pretty aggressive thing to do. If you
actually are scaling every single day
and you're starting off with a rather
reasonable, you know, like couple
hundred bucks or even like a thousand
bucks, it goes a long way really quick
within a 30-day window. However, the
safer strategy like the 10 to 30% a day
strategy is typically better to bias
towards when you have people involved.
So, when you have people involved, you
have to learn to do closer math. We
actually have an entire video on this
channel dedicated to closer math. It was
at one of my inner circle mastermind
talks where we do our four time a year
quarterly masterminds. It's all rich
people trying to get a hell of a lot
richer. We do one-on-one calls, weekly
group calls, unlimited access to AI
Jeremy trained on a little over 4
million data points. By the way, we also
have an incredibly wide, super in-depth
course library for all the inner circle
members. And in addition to that, we
have a group chat, very active, full of
rich people trying to get a hell of a
lot richer. There are a lot of
qualification criterias in order to
join. There's a link for it down in the
description if you would like to check
that out, as well as a course called
Master Internet Marketing. We take our
education company very seriously, unlike
a lot of these other clowns out here.
So, moral of the story is, if you want
to get into an education product that is
very highly reviewed and well regarded,
check out the links down in the
description. But at one of those
masterminds for the inner circle, I did
a specific lesson that I published here
on YouTube on scaling math and closer
math, which you need to be able to do
when you are considering how you're
going to scale your ad campaigns. Just
because you could scale something
extremely aggressively doesn't mean that
it's appropriate to scale something
extremely aggressively. You understand?
You have to be able to balance when you
do what. And to a degree, it's very
important when people are involved to
factor in their hiring cycles. So, as
with sales people, it can take anywhere
from three to four weeks, sometimes
longer than that, to get new closers,
new setters onto the account, on the
calendars, ready to book calls into.
It's not always just a,
>> "Hey, I can scale the campaign. Let's
throw some more [__] clothes on onto
the account."
>> There's a difference between marketing
knobs and people, as Mr. Josh Troy would
say. So, anyway, long story short, these
are three of arguably many different
scaling strategies that you can choose
to deploy. Naturally, I'm going to hold
back on you here on YouTube because,
hey, you're watching this [__] for free.
Go buy one of my programs and learn all
the other scaling strategies. links down
in the description. And at the very
least, subscribe to the channel if you
haven't done so already. Check out some
of my other videos. They're all bangers
and they're all lessons on scaling up to
million-dollar months. No earning
claims, no income claims, just lessons
around scaling to million-dollar months.
Okay, go get richer. Toxin.